and the Los Angeles Times reports NBA
Finals MVP Kawhi Leonard is headed to
the Clippers the California native joins
the team after spending last year with
the Toronto Raptors the free agent made
the decision after the Clippers acquired
a second star Paul George of the
Oklahoma City Thunder OKC gets at least
five draft picks in exchange for the
six-time all-star Leonard is expected to
get 142 million dollars over four years
just last month he helped the Raptors
clinch their first NBA title and he is
the first in this new NBA for agency era
to leave a championship team and go
somewhere else who saw that in the NFL
allow this boy MVP suddenly goes to
another team but this is an hour they
just had the sports expert that affect
the Raptors huge huge yeah yes but so
many people thought he was one of the
Lakers to join LeBron and and Anthony
Davis that didn't happen
different super and the Clippers gave up
four first-round draft picks together
yeah wholly unprotected we were talking
about this morning it's crazy